the Joe Rogan experience well that's
what's interesting to me is how some
animals their progress or their
evolution remains stagnant like
crocodiles are essentially the same way
they were tens of millions of years ago
yep whereas humans it's this market
change over the last half a million
years a spectacular change you know or
two million years ago the doubling of
the human brain size yep really quickly
right special special moments in
evolution but then other things don't
grow at all but then you have these
lions that get trapped on this island
like okay we got to get way bigger right
I think we got to [ __ ] up these
Buffalo's the only thing we can eat you
can't [ __ ] up a buffalo if you're little
right and the bigger survive and those
are the ones that bred
I mean it's so interesting to see how
this stuff sort of plays out and that
we're studying it and really over the
last only few hundred years are really
getting an understanding of it even less
than that I mean we're really only
starting to understand it on a big
picture now yeah it is amazing and
everything in between like you said
these these you know crocodiles reaching
their pinnacle of evolution on tens of
millions of years ago and us constantly
avoid it's just it's insane the world
the living world is so fascinating have
you ever seen the video of these people
they're in a crocodile Park and they're
feeding these crocodiles and this lady's
like Chuck and chickens like chickens
out oh yeah and then the one crocodile
bites the other crocodiles leg off and
does the death roll note and like I'm
straight even moves mm-hmm it's just
like leg comes off and just was like
what the [ __ ] bro yeah it doesn't even
move it doesn't react in pain just
nothing I know the exact video telling I
went totally viral yeah he just rolls
and the leg just pops right and it was
wallows his foot swallows his buddy's
foot like [ __ ] a it's it's not it's
not absolutely not so that is a cleanup
machine yeah that's a 65 million year
old cleanup machine yep and they figured
out this is a great it's like a hammer
yeah you know how to make a hammer right
right there's no new hammers exactly
right hammers like this is it there's a
stick and then the end there's a metal
thing and bang bang bang yeah hammer
that's a hammer and it's a perfect tool
yeah it's perfect yep I mean there's a
bit different sized hammers you got a
came in yep
you got a Nile crocodile exactly right
that is a very good analogy I'm gonna
use that the next time that someone asks
please do explain that because that's
genius it's
this is a hammer it's like they nailed
it there's no reason to make another
knife night your knives right sharp edge
handle the bottom got it right it's
exactly right now I love crocodilians I
think they're just so interesting I
don't know if I told you this story we
when we were in my anmar we were
retracing the ramree massacre you
familiar with the ramree massacre no
you'll love this so during World War two
when the Japanese were holding ramree
island in Burma Myanmar the Allies came
in and started making the Japanese
retreat in the course of like two days a
thousand Japanese soldiers were eaten by
crocodiles by saltwater crocodile yeah
so they were retreated days days I mean
some reports say it was over a couple
weeks but the general consensus is a
thousand soldiers were eaten by
crocodiles in a very short amount of
time and it was this kind of perfect
storm of situations where because there
are all these soldiers they were eating
all the prey all the crocodiles were
particularly hungry because of that did
when the Allies pushed all the Japanese
back into the swamps you know they
started screaming and one scream would
trigger all the others just like all the
crocodiles to get into a frenzy and it
just wiped out this entire populace of
people that ran through the swamp so we
went to retrace these steps to figure it
out we're like why did this happen to
try and understand it better and while
we were there this kid got attacked by a
crocodile that was a hundred years old
so probably the same animal that had
eaten people during World War one or one
of them right and we we saved this kid's
life like we got to the village and he
had just been pulled out from this croc
attack his arm was broken in like 25
places he was torn up he had lacerations
all over his leg his ankle his arm and
we should get him out of the crocodiles
mouth
we didn't so he fought off the crocodile
basically and then the buddy he was with
fishing pulled him into the boat and got
him back to the village what a savage
that kid is cut off a [ __ ] crocodile
and a big one how did he do it we don't
know we were so focused on saving the
kid because myself and one other guy had
medical training so we were stopping the
bleeding and bandaging him up and we had
the only speedboat because we had to get
to this island and this is very very
remote so
you got this kid on the speedboat and
got him back to a hospital and he lived
I think he lost the arm but you know he
was just going to bleed out and die
right there in the village 100-year old
croc now there probably was one of the
crocodiles that ate the Japanese people
during the massive rat remark yeah god
damn my friend Jim shocky was in Africa
and they had hired him to hunt
crocodiles that were terrorizing this
one village these people had fenced off
this area where they could get water and
clean and do deuce and crocodiles had
figured out a way to get through that
and everyone in the village had like a
bite mark or a missing hand a bite on
their head like the so many people had
lost loved ones and friends right while
he was there a woman who was washing
clothes got killed by a crocodile
while he was in the village and these
are Nile crocodiles right enormous you
have a 20 foot long plus huge killing
machines and these are you know I try
and dispel anybody that says to me oh
these animals were hunting people and
I'm like no they were not crocodiles are
do you know what I mean crocodiles will
hunt human beings they will lock in
outside of a small village or an area
that someone's collecting water they'll
spend weeks watching studying the
pattern learning the behavior and just
wait for the perfect time where they can
sink under sit right there waiting for
someone to gather water in my opinion
they're not distinguishing that from
another prey animal they just know this
thing's coming to water here at this
pattern and they will absolutely target
people 100% they don't care if you're a
person I think that's a weird thing
about people we feel like we have some
sort of a deal right well they're not
really after you sharks aren't after
people you have a treaty with sharks are
you talking about Matt you know like
people have this weird thing about
animals you know and you know when
animals find out how easy we are to eat
yeah then it becomes a real problem yeah
I mean Lions of Tsavo right those famous
Lions they were they were smart people
it goes to the dark that's a great movie
fantastic movie yeah people they knew
that people were easy prey and they're
like cool we're gonna keep eating them
once they get a few meals
not bad [ __ ] real easy to catch yeah
the opposite of fast food yeah with like
muscles growing on the beach yeah
totally yeah
[Applause]